. I guess they're really more like Internet
tubes via Dischord David Pakman dotcom slash
dischord is the place.
Let's talk to Tim from New York, Tim from
New York.
You're on the air.
Tim from New York, please, on your cell phone,
you'll be able to talk to me.
And last chance for Tim from New York.
No, Tim from New York, let's go instead to
Tyler from Australia, Tyler from Australia.
You were on the air.
What's going on there?
Hi, David Tatum, good, how are you?
I'm doing great.
Earlier today on Twitter, I saw a picture
of a U.S. flag with fifty two stars.
And now that the Dems have the Senate, the
House and the presidency, I was wondering
what your opinion is or if you think it's
possible that we could have maybe one or two
more states are given statehood.
It would be absolutely fantastic.
I am very significantly supportive of it.
I think D.C. as a democratic state is obvious
because it's so overwhelmingly Democratic.
I actually think it's a little less clear
in terms of Puerto Rico because there is actually
a more conservative contingent there.
And if Puerto Rico were to become a state,
I think you would see Republicans pour in
resources to try to get a senator there.
So I think that it is on balance, D.C. plus
Puerto Rico is absolutely good for Democrats.
I think if you're assuming it would be all
Democrats, you may be wrong, but I would be
hugely supportive of that.
And I would love to see Democrats in control
of the House, Senate and the White House take
that up and look at making that a reality.
Yeah, I was pretty much certain that the D.C.
area would go heavily towards the Democrats,
but.
Right.
I was a bit more worried about the Puerto
Rico area because it's like a bit more of
that Latino vote.
And yeah, but remember, the Latino vote, the
Latino vote is very left other than Cuban-Americans,
but that can still mean you have thirty five
percent.
Thirty eight percent, 41 percent.
That would still be I don't know exactly what
the numbers are in Puerto Rico.
You still end up with some Republican members
of Congress and maybe even a senator, depending
on who chooses to vote with those numbers.
It's just less overwhelming in Puerto Rico.
Yeah, right.
So it could even balance out with just like
a one for one.
I don't think.
I think I think it would lean blue, but it's
just not there's some people who are like
this.
It'll be all Democrats.
And I think that that's probably not true.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, thank you very much.
My pleasure.
Great to great to hear from you